hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica I've
spared you the time I already went out
and gathered all the materials necessary
for the moonpool so with that being said
that's what we're gonna build so I got
to figure out I don't know exactly the
optimal location with which to do this
but I can only assume that it needs to
be attached to building and then have an
area of which you can yeah see this is
this is what I thought the problem was
gonna be because oh hello can I have it
I could just have it completely
separately oh I could do that or I could
join my base together and then be
efficient in that regard but I think I'd
try to cut corners and not do it the
proper way but it feels like oh all
right here we go this one's to me so I'm
gonna put it right exactly here which I
don't know if this is good or bad but it
doesn't matter to me so long as I can
get my seamoth in and out which I can
and that's cool it's like a little
pressure vessel does anyone remember
deep blue sea we're on samuel l.jackson
was standing by the edge of that that's
gonna be it connected by itself oh
that's delightful
I didn't even no no no no that was gonna
do that okay now everything is gonna be
okay well everything's probably not
gonna be okay I'm still stranded on an I
on a planet of water in a fully hostile
ocean with almost nothing that I can eat
in fact I'm gonna get some horrible
alien STDs just by eating the fish that
are here and I'm never gonna see my
family and friends again and for all I
know it's kind of an interstellar
situation where the time vortex has been
bad we're orbiting a black star and
gravitation is a little weird here and
they're all dead and old so that could
be a possibility all right yay how bout
I go
don't mind me bursting right through the
window oh that's nice okay so now that I
got a moon pool I got to figure out how
I'm supposed to be able to enhance this
thing
how am I supposed to be able to enhance
this thing once I got the moonpool I
wasn't a hundred percent sure what I was
supposed to be doing with it
oh no oh here we go
build this in the moonpool to upgrade
the seamoth okay you'd think that that
would have been obvious but alright I'm
gonna okay we're fine here everything is
cool everything is awesome so I got a
not gonna do that for some reason that's
just not automatically available oh wow
oh also I discovered in the update that
they made they changed the way that this
runs out of energy and now does recharge
properly without giving you a seizure
but it does this too
[Music]
so you to listen to that while you stay
home the ocean blue anyway job at each
object chapter two oh wow I got all the
pieces didn't mean to do that
oh well good enough for me I'm gonna
upgrade my seamoth and nothing you can
do is ever gonna stop me and then I'm
gonna need to go out and get resources
again after I build the modification
station because nothing is ever complete
here and you constantly constantly
constantly have to upgrade okay I don't
mind
cuz I got my moonpool and I got my baby
and I'm gonna do what I need to do to
build the thing that I need to build and
it's gonna be right here no I don't have
the titanium yet oh I'm a big dumb dick
okay so where does this go where do I
put this old machine II weenie
oh whoa saw green so whoa ah-ha
Shantay goes right is it there okay um
okay okay okay all right you know okay
I'm not gonna question it I got a place
it gave me the place it doesn't make
sense doesn't make a lot of sense
Oh God stone fabricator oh oh I can give
it a name Oh
USS USS [ __ ] duck oh no I can't put
all of them in it's the USS [ __ ] duck
all right fine then I'm just gonna take
out the USS I'm gonna name it
[ __ ] a duck my little ship the [ __ ]
duck
the USS [ __ ] duck it's gonna be
bright pink very intense and the other
one's gonna be equally intense of
rawrr yellow USS [ __ ] duck name needs
to be bright and yellow done okay now
how do i upgrade it not telling me what
I need to know okay here we go
seam up the big beastie all
reinforcements let's see I need the
pressure compensator plasteel ingot and
computer chips yes I sure hope this one
doesn't blow up because that would be a
travesty a horrible horrible travesty
why can't I see what that needed all the
way over here I'm out of silver oh no I
know it's having these silver left
I have to go farm some or maybe I could
just make some plasteel cuz that would
be a lot more helpful than situation
then when I'm doing here I know I have
lithium I know I have yet
let's see diamonds aluminium oxide no
lithium in sight oh [ __ ]
it looks like my oh [ __ ] why is this
blood oil taking up so much space
there's my lithium I knew for a fact
that it will be here stupid boy oil all
right that should be enough that should
be enough I'm not a hundred percent sure
if it is enough it should be enough I
forgot about that yeah miss you
yes you titanium ingot yes you are
that's a genius but you know you never
got me actually I'd probably do good
with two because it's cumulative I did
my research on it it's additive so each
individual upgrade allows you to go 200
meters deeper which is good but I don't
have everything that I knew that is a
tiny little itty-bitty upgrade are you
kidding me this tiny itty bitty thing is
gonna make it so that this can go deeper
really that's what it can do
oh good cuz I keep bumping into stuff so
if I can actually get some defense on
here that would be lovely and then if I
can get one more one more of the do
daddy McNabb erse then I'll be good and
then I can go exploring the actual ocean
and have a fun time being an adventurer
er were all right let's go get some more
and hopefully some silver - okay I got
some silver I'm going out of my goddamn
mind silver what the hell is that cool
that would bear oh yeah I've been in the
ocean way too long and I bought my boys
anyway we're the only goddamn Salvage re
salvaged up in this area
piece yeah goddamn garbage but I got
some so far
I seriously I'm losing my mind oh whoa
whoa hey whoa can't touch the ow oh god
no no oh I thought I was dying
oh okay Wow still you can see my panic
why I would be panicking as such the way
that I did that so don't judge me what
do I got I got enough
I got enough I got enough to do the
thing that I wanted to do I'm going to
die no oh my god am I just skirting on
the very edges of death this entire time
cuz I'm a loser
okay back to work everybody calm down
it's fine okay so I got another seamoth
pressure compensator which goes right in
there I'm gonna put the hull upgrade on
the front because it's more artistically
pleasing to the eye and I'm gonna
explore this torpedo option that was
presented to me it seems kind of cool Oh
torpedos huh just that easy just that
simple and I get torpedos I get three of
them for only two titanium that seems
kind of nice how do I do that's not what
I wanted
craphole oh my god this one only has a
10% health that doesn't seem good can I
get back in please thank you didn't mean
to actually hop in here I need to find
like some way to repair my seamoth I
don't know why I can't do that right
here that would be helpful but oh well
the [ __ ] doc wants to blast some
things with tor pods how do how do after
is he at the back
that the torpedoes in I'm a little lost
okay let maybe I'll look up how to use
the torpedoes
ah okay I don't have the seamoth torpedo
system the seamoth torpedo system is an
upgrade that you find a plan to
somewhere along the line so I've got a
seal off here and it's got some cool
things going on with it but what it
doesn't have is health it's doing poorly
so what I need is I need the repair dude
a debugger okay all right okay okay I
remember now I remember I remember
personal tools the welder magnesium
crash powder and titanium now crash
powder if you guys remember came from
the little bastards that blew up in your
face and it no do good that but it do
that lock these little [ __ ] so this
one already wanted come at me bro come
at me bro come at me bro
Oh can't dig these moves and you're done
so if this doesn't work I am though I am
a hundred percent bone how am I supposed
to get crash powder
maybe I gotta like scan it first do I
gotta do that and then I okay that did a
whole lot of crap for me thanks
databank fauna flora
CrashPlan exploitable how do I get from
inner leaves
well that died good I do I do more oh no
my boned
do I have to cheat I refuse to cheat why
can't the moonpool just repair it that
would be delightful alright so here's
the rub I've got a seamoth that's been
fully upgraded to go down beyond crush
depth in fact it can go down
damn near 425 meters below the surface
the problem is I've only got 10% health
now I do have reinforced plating but if
I'm not careful I'm gonna blow up this
brand-new seamoth and all of its
upgrades with it and if there's one
thing that I am it's not careful so the
first thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
down here into the depths down here very
carefully because down here was the
first place that I explored that could
possibly be and I had no idea that it
even existed now the thing is there is a
theoretical limit to how far down you
can take a seamoth because it only
expands at 200 some odd meters every
time but look at me go mium do go fine
well me I'm not going there
woah me I'm not
fun what is that is that it's at a crash
powder maybe you give give give give
you're dead Oh your dad oh my my cook
died I I didn't lose all that much stuff
what the hell I got blasted oh no my
things death no my seamoth is down there
Oh ass Oh boobs boobs and ass and balls
I gotta go back I don't even know if I'm
gonna make it I've got a limping limping
limping sloshed glider I don't know it's
called whatever it is it's limping with
barely any battery left and my oxygen is
gonna go down way faster once I get
below look at my shadow go I'm a glider
I need my seamoth i better get there I
don't think I'm gonna get there oh it's
not gonna end well for me oh look at
this
all right down to the wire Oh delightful
delightful please don't blow ourselves
up okay we're good we're okay whew that
was not fun so let's try to avoid the
giant plumes of volcanic activity whoa
deep sea Peters cool I want one an
oculus I've always wanted one great
animation of holding it
wow this looks super dangerous that's so
cool that's suck oh oh whoa oh oh oh
hello okay all right don't know what
that was all about I never want to know
what it's about again place your bets
now who bet markiplier blows up his
brand-new upgraded seamoth ends up with
him crying in a heap in the corner of
them from there he can't even talk right
what a loser definitely gonna lose out
on everything he ever loved I get a run
into a giant in deep sea creatures are
gross I don't even know if I'm going in
the right direction cuz it's got to be
like another way out there's got to be
like a boom while I'm here I'm just
gonna grab some more lithium real good
because lithium gold I don't need gold I
got plenty of gold give me my left there
nice music ooh
secret secrets - where am I whoa
hello what the hell are you whoa hey hey
buddy how you doing you're a big piece
of the aurora you're a giant chunk of
the aurora
how did you get all the way over here
what even are you I can go in you all
right then let's explore I don't even
know where this is in relation to
anything else I'll wait there Wow hey
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Nelly whoa
whoa whoa oh whoa whoa don't follow
ah interesting
what are you whoa what are you whoa okay
Wow
oh cool little maze of crawl ways nice
nice okay so that didn't pop out the
right place there's got to be some
secret goodies in here there's got to be
they wouldn't have built something like
this and put in mazes with absolutely
dick in here there's got to be something
cool it's hard with everyone tilt your
head like me jeez hello oh you better
back off
I'm crazy oh yeah you're trapped in here
though whoa oh god Occident forgot about
the oxygen problem that's definitely not
good Oh
oh boy get out get out get out get out
get out get out get out oh boy oh boy oh
boy C month J boss show your mouth baby
there we go
Oh things were going black all right
we're good so there's something else in
here there's got to be there's got to be
like a good there's something but I will
figure that out in the next video I will
also be going more cave exploring and
going deep down into the depths where I
could not go previously so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what else I should do I will
eventually get started on that new
farming update and see what's going on
so thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]